[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
c'est une bonne question question qu'on
se pose tous les jours à vrai dire
dans l'ensemble la ligne que j'emprunte
qui qui dessert versailles-chantiers
paris montparnasse et votre faim il en
pense quoi
ma femme est l'autre à mon frère année
votre frère ac c'est une blague lancée
ça je me suis je vous allez bien mûri
très bien c'est pourquoi non non c'est
une blague ou non à mes josy poueyto
moore au tampon je vous ai plus pour mon
frère peut excuser de dos j'avais des
problèmes au niveau des aides et urinent
dans les transports pendant les couloirs
score un grand show je pense qu'ils en
pensent la même chose en fait
tous les trucs ça va j'ai raté quoi
alors que dans d'autres lieux entre la
leçon n'a pas aussi souvent par contre
dès fois faire l'amour
un effort sur les heures de pointe
peut-être mais votre chat ne penses quoi
chipadze heures on m'a oublié
tu vas j'arrive de la caf gta iv via
deux secondes ça va ouais ça va mais je
suis surpris je m'attendais pas te voir
mais ouais mais parce que je suis comme
ça moi j'aime les visites comment on
appelle ça comment visite surprise ils
sont pas une visite avait une sorte à
cowes
et tous les autres jours 200 balles je
vous dis pas quand même fait des années
on est content mais les 200 balles
[Musique]